Wir blicken mal wieder auf den Investoren-Deal bei der DFL, wenn er denn überhaupt zustande kommt. Das ist schon mal die erste Frage. Inzwischen ist ja nur noch einer im Rennen und dazu will ich mal heute mit zwei besonderen Gästen sprechen. Christoph Neßhöver ist hier vom Manager-Magazin und Jannik Tillar von Kapital und die werden mir und euch heute alles erklären über Private Equity, über CVC und wie man eigentlich vielleicht auch aus einer anderen Perspektive auf diesen Deal blickt. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Ich freue mich. Und nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Was müssen Sie den Private-Equity-Investoren versprechen, um das Geld zu bekommen? Was sind die Wachstum- also die Wertsteigerungsraten? Sind die berühmten Verdopplungen alle zwei Jahre, Vervierfachungen in vier Jahren? Ist das das, was Sie sagen müssen?
Jetzt kaufe ich Unternehmen, also zum Beispiel Douglas, das kennen Sie Tipico, Messer-Industriegase, Breitling. Deswegen muss ich eine Breitling-Uhr auch tragen. Kaufen wir, behalten wir dann vier bis fünf Jahre, versuchen, von good to great, also ein gutes Unternehmen noch besseres zu machen und dann mehr Geld zu verkaufen.
Also um es mal ein bisschen theoretisch zu formulieren, solche Initiativen besprechen wir anhand eines Businessplans und da schauen wir uns an. Und dann entscheiden wir und weiter in irgendwelche konkreten Zahlen werde ich jetzt auch nicht gehen.
Aber schon sportlich, was man sich vornimmt?
Ja, mit Private Equity zu arbeiten ist sportlich, aber das ist es ja gerade, was es so toll macht, weil man eben schnell nach vorne denken kann und schnell unternehmen kann, weil Unternehmen oder Unternehmertum kommt ja von etwas unternehmen und man die Hebel eben schnell umlegen kann.
Schnelle Hebe, die umgelegt werden können. Übrigens so schnell, Tina Müller ist jetzt gar nicht mehr CEO von Douglas, die ist zu VLeda gewechselt. Wir müssen auch gleich nochmal über die Schuldenstruktur von Douglas reden, da habe ich nämlich auch noch eine Anschlussfrage in Bezug auf CVC. Aber wenn du das ebenso hörst, Jannik, hohe Erwartung ist ja klar, hat ja die DFL an sich selbst auch, aber dann auch ein hohes Tempo in der Umsetzung. Glaubst du, das kann funktionieren?
Es kann zumindest nicht schaden. Ich glaube, da sind die Strukturen so verkrustet, dass ein bisschen Tempo ja gar nicht mal schaden würde, wie gesagt. Also, ob es funktionieren kann, ich glaube, es muss funktionieren. Also, das ist der Anspruch eines private Accruities und ich glaube, da sind sich auch alle einig, wenn du so jemanden an Bord holst, dann musst du dieses Tempo auch mitgehen. Und ob das dann klappt, das ist eine ganz andere Frage, das steht auf einem ganz anderen Papier. Aber, ja, ich glaube, alle sind sich darüber einig, dass das der Anspruch ist und dass man sich darauf dann verständigt, wenn man diesen an Bord holt.
Und Christoph, glaubst du, die DFL kriegt das hin, wenn jetzt schon – also, wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, andere private equity Firmen haben gesagt, die DFL ist kein guter Partner. Und auch deswegen hat sich wahrscheinlich Blackstone zurückgezogen. Das würde ja auch jetzt nicht dafür sprechen, dass man sich dann in der Mediaco, man überlegt sich dann, wie wollen wir die OTT-Platform machen, welchen Content wollen wir für die digitalen Kanäle? Und dann sagen alle 36 Profiklubs, sagen, mega geil, danke, dass ihr damit kommt. Wir haben nämlich gestern schon jemand eingestellt, der das macht. Und morgen habt ihr die ersten Ergebnisse. Ganz so funktioniert es ja nicht in der DFL.
Also wenn ich da schnell höre, was die Frau Müller da gesagt hat, dann passt das eigentlich diametral nicht zur DFL, sage ich jetzt mal. Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen gemein. Ich halte das für sehr schwierig dann in der Zusammenarbeit, dass das funktionieren kann. Ich glaube auch, dass, also wenn wir, Frau Manager Marketing, wir machen ja viele Geschichten über Unternehmen, Vermieterunternehmen oder andere Unternehmen. Und oft ist der Angriffspunkt unser Angriffspunkt, weil wir glauben, dass die Governance nicht funktioniert. Also die Gremien, die du hast, die funktionieren entweder nicht, weil die Leute nicht miteinander klagen oder weil die Gremienstruktur, das hast du bei Vermieterunternehmen, des bei sehr großen sehr oft, sich gegenseitig blockieren. Und da ist die DFL meiner Meinung nach ein klassisches Beispiel. Also wenn wir jetzt eine DFL-Geschichte machen würden, dann würde man erst mal sagen, die Governance kann so eigentlich funktionieren. Mir ist klar, dass die DFL ein sehr besonderes Unternehmen ist durch die Struktur. Aber du bekommst ja immer sehr, sehr große, immer größere Fliehkräfte, desto weiter die Interessen der einzelnen Stakeholder, wie man so schön sagt, der einzelne Mitglieder in dem Fall bei der DFL auseinandergehen. Und die Interessen der Groß- und der Kleinklubs, erst mal solop gesagt, sind halt mittlerweile so dermaßen unterschiedlich geworden, dass es für die DFL so extrem schwierig ist, geschlossen aufzutreten und immer Kompromisse machen. Kompromisse musst du immer machen, aber wenn natürlich – das ist ja kein neues Argument, zum Beispiel der großen Klubs Bayern, Dortmund usw. die sagen, naja, ein Großteil der Werthaltigkeit der Deutschen, der Bundesliga besteht darin, dass wir da mitspielen. Und nicht, dass Eintracht Braunschweig mitspielt oder Erzgebirge Aue oder so. Da ist ja auch was dran. Also wenn ich jetzt versuche, in Asien Augsburg gegen Heidenheim zu vermarkten im Gegensatz zu Bayern gegen Dortmund, dann ist natürlich klar, was dabei rauskommt. Die haben schon einen Punkt. Und ich meine, es gibt ja nicht wenige, die schon länger sagen, eigentlich müsste die Bundesliga auch diesen Schritt vorziehen, den andere Ligen auch schon gemacht haben, dass man eben die Liga-Verband aufteilt. Also trennt praktisch in Erste und Zweite Liga zumindest – und selbst wenn man das jetzt mal theoretisch durchdenkt, selbst die Erste Liga, wenn die jetzt einen Eigenverband nur noch hätte, mit 18, dann haben wir mal DFL 1 sozusagen, oder DFL Erste Liga, dann hast du selbst da Unterschiede, hast du jetzt aktuell dann Heidenheim und Bayern oder Bochum und Bayern. Allein da sind die Unterschiede schon so riesig, dass selbst das schon schwierig wäre, in Gemeinschaftssicht zu kommen. Jetzt mal unabhängig von den ganzen Fragen Solidarität und was die DFL an die anderen abgibt, alles geschenkt. Das heißt, um eine Partnerschaft wie mit diesen Private-Equity-Typen, die genau wissen, was sie wollen, die, wie Frau Müller sagt, die machen Druck, Druck, Druck, schnell, schnell, schnell. Aber die machen es auch, wie ich jetzt nicht sage, per se immer nur schlecht. Manchmal ist Druck ja auch gut, damit man was geschafft kriegt. Aber um das im Sinne des Fußballs auch zu nutzen, also die Chancen zu ergreifen, die das auch bietet, ohne Frage, und die viele Manager ja auch sehen, musst du auf Seiten des Fußballs auch wirklich handlungsfähig sein, einigermaßen geschlossen auftreten, auch um dich nicht über den Tisch ziehen zu lassen von Herrn DeBelius in Zukunft oder so. Weil die schon natürlich auch gucken auf ihren Vorteil. Das ist halt ein Investor und Punkt. Und da bin ich skeptisch, ob die DFL das hinkriegt. Und es gibt auch Leute, die dir dann sagen, die dafür sind, die würden das öffentlich nicht sagen, aber die sagen dir dann ja, wir hoffen ja darauf, dass wenn dann die Partnerschaft kommt, dann entsteht so ein Sog und mehr Klubs verstehen, dass sie da jetzt mitziehen müssen. Sonst haben wir nichts davon so ungefähr. Und dann hast du so zu ahnen, wenn du bist jetzt zu feige, sag jetzt mal, oder du bist zu bang, um die Revolution von innen anzustoßen, ob es jetzt nur eine Trennung ist oder eine Neuverhandlung der Beziehungen, da gibt es untereinander, wie auch immer man das jetzt nennen will. Und das kommt dann so indirekt rein, weil da kommt dann der Investor und der schüttelt jetzt den Baum und plötzlich sagen alle möglichen Leute, oh, wir müssen wirklich was ändern, weil sonst sind wir nicht in der Lage, das zu nutzen. Ich finde, das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, der so unterschwellig ist, dass eigentlich alle wissen oder viele wissen, die DFL ist extrem schwer zu führen, extrem schwer als Organisation zusammenzuhalten. Und jetzt kommt der Partner und wenn du mit dem Partner klarkommen willst, nicht nur klarkommen, sondern auch davon was haben willst, dann musst du dich zusammenraufen. Und wenn ich das schon nicht aus meinen eigenen Interessen heraus hinkriege, dann mache ich das über diese Partnerschaft, weil die uns dann zwingt. Das ist vielleicht naiv, vielleicht führt es eher zum Gegenteil. Die Fliehkräfte nehmen noch stärker zu und der Mann fliegt ja auseinander. Aber das Argument ist durchaus wichtig für einige, aus meiner Wahrnehmung, weil die sagen, das könnte sozusagen der, wie soll ich sagen, der zweit, also fast der wichtigere Gewinn für die DFL sein, weil die uns zur Einheit zwingt.
Ja, oder halt zum Aufkunden der Solidargemeinschaft, womit dann die Fans noch mehr Grund hätten, dagegen zu protestieren.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja auch, wie man das dann, man kann sich ja auch andere Modelle vorstellen, aber es ist echt schwierig, weil du hast eine gewachsene Tradition, du hast sehr, sehr, sehr unterschiedliche, ich sag jetzt mal einfach Unternehmen, sechs Unternehmen, die ganz unterschiedlichen Blickwinkel haben. Manche denken global, machen Büros in Shanghai auf, und andere denken an bis zum drittnächsten Dorf, weil das ist nämlich deren Einzugsgebiet und denen ist egal, was in Asien passiert. Und die arbeiten zusammen und die sind aufeinander angewiesen.
Und du wolltest auch eine Zwei-Drittel-Mehrheit.
Nein, nein, alles klar, ich red jetzt nur so ins Blaue rein, aber dass das nicht so funktionieren kann oder sehr schlecht funktioniert auf Dauer ist eigentlich offensichtlich. Und durch den Deal könnte, wenn er dann zustande kommt, ein Druck entstehen, darüber nochmal neu nachzudenken. Wie das aussehen kann – ich bin ja nicht Herr Merkel, Herr Lenz oder Herr Watzfeld zum Glück, muss nicht mit denen tauschen – das ist Hölle, höllisch schwierig. Aber die Diskussion, die läuft und die Fragen stehen im Raum und die werden eher noch lauter oder noch deutlicher herausstehen, wenn du dann einen Partner hast, weil der wird dir die Fragen ständig stellen.
Ja genau und ich meine positiv formuliert könnte man auch sagen, vielleicht kommen sie dann über den Partner endlich mal darauf, dass das Produkt halt schlecht ist und das dafür auch eine andere, also dass es vielleicht ein Problem ist, dass die Unternehmen so unterschiedliche Umsätze haben, dass die logischerweise ganz anderes Marktverständnis und so weiter haben. Aber eben es kann auch sein, dass dann über ein Partner eben es genau zu dieser Abspaltung kommt und weil der Partner muss sich ja auch absichern. CVC hat das in La Liga als Problem, dass da nämlich vier Vereine gesagt haben, wir stimmen diesem Deal, der über 50 Jahre läuft, stimmen wir nicht zu, weil wir einzeln vermarktet viel besser sind. Das ist überhaupt krass. 50 Jahre, also das ist, kann man ja noch mal nachgucken, was Chicago mit seinen Parkgebühren gemacht hat. Gibt es sehr, sehr schöne Videos.
Wobei ich da noch eine Unterscheidung vornehmen würde, also nicht das Produkt ist schlecht, sondern das Medienprodukt ist schlecht. Das ist mir dann schon irgendwie wichtig.
Ja, wobei vielleicht ist auch das Produkt nicht mehr ganz so gut, wie man gedacht hat, weil eben du hast eben nicht mehr über den vollen Start geht.
Aber für diesen Fall des Investors ist es nicht so wichtig. Also der Investor interessiert sich ja für das Medienprodukt.
Ja genau, aber das Medienprodukt wird doch gestaltet durch das Produkt vor Ort. Und wenn ich NFL oder andere US-Sportübertragungen sehe und da ist die Stadion nicht voll, dann fällt es mir immer auf.
NFL wird nicht voll sein, aber ja.
Gut, bei den letzten Spielen war es dann doch durchaus so. Und oft im vierten Viertel. Aber genau, bei der Bundesliga hast du zum Anpfiff schon viele halbvolle Stadien. Und was signalisiert das nach außen? Also du erzählst, es ist Unterhaltungsindustrie. Wir müssen hier so tun, als ob jedes Spiel das Allerwichtigste des Planeten wäre und dass man auch unbedingt verfolgen muss. Wie jetzt – es tut mir leid, dass ich immer diese Teams nenne, aber es sind halt die Hoffenheim gegen Wolfsburg. Im Ausland musst du als Medienbetrieb so tun, als ob das das wichtigste Spiel der Welt wäre. Und das machen die auch in ihrer Übertragung. Mensch, jetzt der große Clash in the Wolves, Meeting finally with the Krichgrow. Brazilianer, ja gut, das sagen sie jetzt nicht. Aber ich gucke ja viel über ESPN und so weiter. Und dann schalten die ins Stadion und du siehst, da sitzen drei Leute auf Höhe der Mittellinie. Also jetzt übertrieben gesagt. Das ist natürlich schon ein Riesenproblem.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Deswegen, mein Plädoyer ist auch den Relegationsplatz durch einen Traditionsplatz erschaffen zu ersetzen. Aber da komme ich nicht weit mit.
Jetzt versucht er sich so reinzusnicken.
Es ist genauso unfair wie ein Relegationsplatz, aber es wird zumindest zu einer Umverteilung von Traditionsteams in die erste Liga führen. Naja, aber ich weiß, dass ich damit nicht durchkomme.
Ich meine, es ist ja klar. Ich darf noch einen Satz sagen, wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen. Das hat ja die DFL immer ausgeschlossen, aber jetzt für den strategischen Prozess. Aber diese Fragen, ob man vielleicht an den Modus was ändern muss, ob man vielleicht an der Liga stammt, sind ja schon seit Jahren gestellt. Also Wolfgang Holzhäuser, ewig bei Bayer Leverkunft, der hat schon vor 50 Jahren gesagt, Leute, denkt mal über Playoffs nach. Wenn ihr euch darüber aufregt, dass die Bayern immer gewinnen, wenn du am Ende wieder am Eishock die letzten acht in Playoffs schickst, dann ist die Chance natürlich größer, dass die Bayern auch mal auf die Nase fliegen und dann holen die vielleicht in der Saison zwar 100 Punkte, aber verlieren dann im Halbfinale gegen Frankfurt oder so, wie ja auch schon mal hin und wieder im Pokalfinale passiert oder in einzelnen Spielen. Das heißt, das ist ein neuer Kick. Das kannst du auch wieder ganz anders. Da kommen wir jetzt auch im Ausland vermarkten, weil das dann einfach in den letzten vier, sechs Wochen der Saison einfach total spannend nochmal würde. Widerspricht der Tradition, weiß ich alles. Widerspricht dem Verständnis, wie die Liga funktionieren soll. Aber die Diskussion ist ja nicht neu. Und wenn du den Nebelius fragen würdest, wie willst du dir das denn alles so vorstellen? Der würde wahrscheinlich sagen, naja, erstmal Liga anders zusammensetzen. Heidenheim raus, Augsburg raus, dafür Schalke, HSV natürlich alle rein, Kaiserslautern, erste Liga, aber das sind die riesengroßen Marken. Die gehören da rein, so wie das in den USA mit den Franchises ist. Können wir nicht kopieren, ich sag's nur. Und dann am besten noch Playoffs. Und das knallt richtig rein. Klar, wird nicht kommen, wissen wir. Aber die Diskussion geht jetzt so zu tun, als wenn das jetzt über den Investor diese Fragen drohen oder die Spieltage auf, das haben wir ja auch alles schon länger diskutiert. Das ist ein bisschen Augenwischerei, weil die Fragen liegen ja auf der Straße. Und die gibt's ja schon viel länger.
Die muss man sich auch unabhängig von einem Investor stellen.
Die sind sowieso im Raum. Und auch die Frage, wie ich das moderner inszeniere. Wir haben ja das Problem mit den leeren Stadien. Habt ihr beide angesprochen? Kenn ich auch. Die haben ja Angst, massiv Angst, dass ihnen die ganzen jungen Leute abhanden kommen. Ist ja schon der Fall. Dann hast du teilweise keinen richtigen Handyanfang im Stadion. Wenn der Stadion nur halb voll ist, bricht alles zusammen. Katastrophe. Die Leute gucken anders heute. Und wenn du die gewinnen willst, die Angst ist ja groß in der Liga, dass du die alle verlierst. Und möglicherweise ist da so ein frischer Blick schon ganz gut. Wenn du es anders inszenieren willst. Nur die Frage ist, das reizt natürlich an den Traditionen. Mal sehen, wie das wird. Aber da müssen die ran. Und das ist auch unabhängig vom strategischen Investor der Fall. Da müssen die ran, sonst würden die weglaufen. Wenn du das nicht zu einem umfassenderen, moderneren, cooleren Produkt umarbeitest oder weiterentwickelst, was eben auch dann diese Zuschauer anzieht, ob nun vor dem Bildschirm oder auch im Stadion, die du erreichen willst, damit es auf Dauer die große Popularität erhalten bleibt.
Aber da sind wir doch schon beim berühmten Punkt rote Linien. Und ehrlich gesagt, ganz viel von dem, was ihr jetzt gesagt habt, klingt nicht so, als ob für CVC das überhaupt nur erträglich sein könnte, sich an diese roten Linien zu halten, weil dann dürften sie eben gar nicht mitreden, bei Spielplan-Gestaltung, bei Anpfiff, bei Modus und so weiter und sofort. Und es gibt ja schon einen Unterschied, ob über den Druck eines Investors diese Themen angegangen werden oder ob sie einfach so angegangen werden. Denn einfach so würde bedeuten, bei den Mitglieder geführten Vereinen, da haben die Fußballfans noch ein Mitspracherecht und darauf weisen sie ja letztlich mit den Protesten aktuell gerade hin. Und das kann man ja auch tatsächlich nicht wegdiskutieren, dass das eine andere Qualität hat, als wenn eben das über CVC kommt. Deswegen die erste Frage, Jannik, kannst du dir überhaupt vorstellen, dass diese roten Linien, selbst wenn sie schriftlich fixiert sind – und ich weiß, liebe DFL, dass es so ist und so weiter, habt ihr ganz toll in eurem FAQ erklärt – aber die können sich doch da gar nicht dran halten, weil sie müssen ja ans Produkt ran.
Also wie genau diese roten Linien aussehen, steht ja auch noch gar nicht fest. Also die Verträge sind ja nicht offen gelegt, deswegen kann man da auch nur ein bisschen spekulieren.
Obwohl alles so transparent ist. Komisch, oder?
Naja, man hätte also dieses 15-seitige Dokument ist ja immerhin da, von der DFL. Das muss man herlassen, auch wenn sich dann Steffen Merkel, glaube ich, selbst in der Süddeutschen beklagt hat, dass das ja alles furchtbar kompliziert in der Kommunikation sei. Einerseits, wenn es zu lang ist, zu kompliziert, wenn es zu kurz ist, ist es nicht ausführlich genug. Richtig. Also abgesehen davon, ich habe auch mit einem Investor gesprochen und ihm genau diese Frage gestellt und er sagte, nie im Leben gibt man eine Milliarde Euro und vertraut dann darauf, dass die anderen das gut machen. Also es wird immer das Interesse geben, mit am Tisch zu sitzen, ob man dann in diese Entscheidung, wiefern man da Einfluss hat, das muss man mal schauen. Aber wo man vielleicht darauf achten müsste, ist jetzt bei der Gremien-Sitzung. Es soll ja vier Instanzen geben, also das Management, den Aufsichtsrat, den Gesellschaftsausschuss und Beirat und da muss man wirklich ganz genau darauf achten, wer dort dann reinkommt. Ob es dann wirklich nur Leute aus den Vereinen sind, oder ob das vielleicht Strommänner werden von CVC. Da gibt es ja schon so ein paar Lobbyisten im Hintergrund, das wird immer wieder so dargestellt, dass dieser Ex-Skybox, Carsten Schmidt zum Beispiel, für CVC lobbyiert hat. Ob der zum Beispiel für CVC dort in irgendeiner dieser Gremien sitzen wird und darüber dann die Interessen von CVC vertritt, dann ist er zwar nicht formal angestellt bei CVC, aber ist zumindest Interessenvertreter vor Ort und kann dort Sachen durchsetzen. Ich glaube, da muss man mal abwarten, was dort passiert, aber ich halte es für ziemlich ausgeschlossen, dass man sich dort nicht ins Operative einmischen wird. Ich glaube, diese Themen Spieltagsplanung usw. das ist nicht das erste Thema, wo die ansetzt werden. Das sind eher so Themen, die nachgelagert eventuell mal in die Diskussion kommen, wenn das Investment nicht so läuft, sich nicht so entwickelt, wie sie es prognostiziert haben. Und wenn das z.B. aber gut läuft und die Ziele erreicht werden, dann kann es auch sein, dass es innerhalb dieser roten Linien bleibt. Deswegen muss man viel abwarten. Das ist Zukunftsmusik. Ich glaube da auch nicht dran, aber man muss es einfach abwarten, glaube ich.
Vielleicht noch ein Satz dazu. Die Bundesliga ist ja jetzt schon dabei, international zu vermarkten mit dieser Bundesliga- International-Tochterfirma. So, jetzt nehmen wir mal an, die kriegen ein Angebot aus gegriffenes Japan. Und da sagt ein Sportcaster oder wer auch immer, ich sage jetzt mal was ganz Irres, wenn wir Montagmittag eurer Zeit, wenn ihr da ein Bundesligaspiel machen würdet, jede Woche, dann sagen wir mal 13 Uhr, ich weiß nicht, wie das mit Japan, die sind ja vor uns, also dann haben die da abends, oder? Richtig? Ja, dann haben die da. Dann können wir das hier live zeigen. Wir kaufen jetzt sozusagen eins pro Spieltag und dafür zahlen wir, ich sage jetzt mal, 100 Millionen oder so, weil es ist für uns das Wert. So, wenn jetzt die Bundesliga International die Geschäftsführung zur DFL geht und das den Klubs vorstellt und sagt, pass auf, wir können hier 100 Millionen Cash dafür kriegen, so. Szenario eins. Szenario zwei ist dasselbe und das macht jetzt CVC, wenn die eingestiegen sind, weil die eben da Kontakte haben und das in Möglichkeit sehen. Wie unterscheidet sich dann die Entscheidungssituation für die Klubs? Also diese Themen werden alle so oder so aufs Tapet kommen und die roten Linien sind immer mal der Gestalt wichtig für die Glaubwürdigkeit der DFL. Andererseits hängt die ja auch stark davon ab, wie viel Geld da reinkommt und dieses Spiegelensparat wirst du immer haben, ob nun mit CVC oder ohne CVC und weiterentwickeln, das hat die DFL immer wieder gesagt, müssen sie das Geschäftsmodell und weiterentwickeln heißt natürlich, im Endeffekt du musst über alles nachdenken. Natürlich gibt es immer wieder Grenzen und du wirst immer gucken, wo sind die Grenzen der Clubs, der Fans. Und die sind in Deutschland teilweise enger gestrickt als in anderen Ligen, das ist auch klar. Aufgrund der Tradition, aufgrund der Fan-Kultur, die ist sicherlich speziell bei uns und das ist auch für die Liga ein großer Wert. Aber im Endeffekt müssen die Clubs immer alle rechnen. Was kommt da rein? Und wenn du so ein Angebot kriegst, dann kann es sein, dass es sich das unterscheidet in der Betrachtung, wer es dir besorgt hat. Aber kommen werden die so oder so. Und du musst dich ja auch eintreiben. Die internationale Gesellschaft, die haben ja auch die Liga-Mente schon öffentlich gesagt, bisher nur sehr überschaubar erfolgreich. Wenn du guckst, was die so im Jahr reinholen zu dem, was andere Ligen da schaffen. Jetzt haben die teilweise auch einen Sprachvorteil, keine Frage. Aber trotzdem ist die Bundesliga, glaube ich auch, immer noch v.a. attraktiv. Zumindest attraktiver als die 200 Millionen, die da jedes Jahr zusammen glauben, was jetzt echt nicht viel ist, im internationalen Vergleich. Also ich glaube, die Dinger werden sowieso kommen. Die roten Linien sind politisch wichtig. Am Ende müssen sich alle fragen, wie viel Geld wollen wir, wie viel Geld brauchen wir und wie wettbewerbsfähig wollen wir sein. Natürlich wird der Partner, ob es um CVC sein wird oder nicht, diese Fragen stellen. Die werden die nerven. Und die Leute in der Liga, die das eigentlich auch gerne diskutieren, würden sich aber nicht trauen, direkt zu sagen, die haben dann jemanden, der sagt, was soll das sein, aber die haben gesagt, die holen dann so und so etwas rein. Das ändert einfach die Diskussion ein bisschen. Das ist so, wie ein Unternehmensberater holt, obwohl er eigentlich weiß, dass es bestimmte harte Schnitte machen muss. Dann holt er halt Roland Berger oder wie die alle heißen und sagen, Roland Berger hat aber gesagt, wir müssen euch jetzt rausschmeißen. Ich sag jetzt mal ganz böse, geht ja nicht immer nur darum. Aber nur als Beispiel, dass du kriegst, die Diskussionslage ändert sich. Und ich weiß nicht, was mit den roten Linien passiert. Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Kann ich nicht sagen. Vielleicht werden die alle gehalten, vielleicht doch nicht. Aber wenn ich einen Partner hole, will ich mich ja entwickeln. Und die Liga sagt selber immer, ob Partner oder nicht, wir müssen und wollen uns entwickeln. Und die Grenzen dafür wirst du, glaube ich, immer wieder neu ziehen müssen angesichts des Angebotes, angesichts der Marktveränderungen, angesichts dessen, was du willst. Wenn irgendwann die Bundesliga sagt, es gibt ja Leute, die eigentlich sagen, dass uns reicht das völlig aus. Wir sind in Deutschland cool und dem Rest ist uns egal. Wir wollen hier toll Fußball inszenieren. Das kann man ja haben. Ich habe ja gar nicht dagegen. Dann brauchst du das alles nicht. Wenn du aber dich ärgerst, dass du nur noch irgendwie 17-jährige Spieler kriegst, wenn du überhaupt glückliche Kriege und alle anderen gehen nach woanders hin, wo es Mehrgeld zu verdienen gibt und du willst das verhindern, dann musst du dir die Frage stellen, was muss ich dafür tun? Also ist es so.
Ich glaube, ein Punkt könnte halt auch sein, eine rote Linie, die relativ schnell übertreten werden könnte, wäre jetzt bei der nächsten rechten Periode die Frage, ob es an ein oder mehrere Anbieter geht. Also das ist dann die Frage, ob Geld Konzept zum Beispiel überwiegt. Das wurde jetzt ja vom Bundeskartellamt entschieden, dass dieses No Single Buyer Rule abgeschafft wird. Also ist es mittlerweile wieder möglich, dann ist ab der kommenden rechten Periode, dass ein Anbieter – sagen wir mal Sky oder The Zone – alle Pakete quasi erwirbt und von Freitags bis Sonntags da durchsenden darf. Und die Frage ist, sind die Einzelteile in Summe mehr wert als ein Gesamtpaket, was man an einen möglichen Partner verkaufen kann? Und es ist ja ein Problem, dass der Fußball sehr limitiert ist und verschlossen ist durch diese verschiedenen Partner, dass man mittlerweile fast 100 Euro zahlt für alle zwei, drei Partner, wenn man auch noch Telekom damit hinzuzieht. Und jetzt das neueste Paket, aber so wäre, dass man sagt, man hätte jetzt nur Sky und zahlt dafür dann 70 Euro. Dann ist es vielleicht für die Fans einfacher, das hinzubekommen über einen Partner. Aber in Summe würde Sky einfach weniger zahlen als die Summe von Sky, The Zone und Telekom. Und dann wird aber ein Investor definitiv sagen, dann nehmen wir lieber die drei Partner anstatt des einen Partners, weil es gibt uns mehr Cashflow. Und langfristig gesehen wäre es vielleicht sinnvoller, das an einen Partner zu geben, weil mehr Fans sich für Fußball interessieren, weil man das langfristig aufbauen kann. Aber man ist ja auch dann als PE seinen Investoren verpflichtet zu sagen, wir möchten möglichst viel Cashflow drin haben. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Punkt, wo man direkt mal gucken kann, hat der PE. Einfluss oder nicht.
Ja, sehr guter Punkt. Und damit sind wir mitten im ganzen Bereich. Was hat den CVC bisher auch im Sport gemacht? Weil wir haben schon mal kurz angedeutet, sie haben die meiste Erfahrung. Und interessanterweise ganz ähnliche Diskussionen, wie sie jetzt hier gab, gab es beim Rugby-Weltverband, wo CVC eben auch eingestiegen ist. Und da hören wir mal kurz Ian Ritchie, der war früher bei Wimbledon der Chef, hat dafür gesorgt, dass Wimbledon Dach bekommen hat und so weiter und so fort, musste da schon Tradition versus Innovation sehr gut austarieren. Also, dem kann man zuhören. Nicht alles, was er sagt, ist, glaube ich, sinnvoll, aber der hat zumindest Vorerfahrung. Und er erzählt mal, wie es jetzt dann im Rugby-Verband zu dieser Entscheidung kam, man sieht krasse Parallelen zu CVC und dann kommen wir mal drüber diskutieren, was haben sie denn bisher so gemacht bei ihren Sportinvestments?
Also denke ich, wie bei allen Dingen, ja, es war ein gutes Kompromiss.
Und ich denke, es ist interessant, wenn du dann in die unabhängige Negotiationphase gehst, die unabhängig involviert hat, Anwesenden, Täter, sogar in einem Fall, mein Lieblingsfavorit war, algebraische Äquationen in einem der Dokumente.
Also, auch hier, die Vereine mussten sich erstmal alle einig werden. Sie wollten keine Kontrolle abgeben und CVC hat sich aber damit beschränkt, quasi erstmal am kommerziellen Mehrerlös beteiligt zu werden. Alles parallel zur Bundesliga. Man könnte jetzt ganz genau gucken, was wird im Rugby gemacht. Da geht es nämlich auch an die Pfrunde ran. Also, Six Nations, das große Rugby-Event. Da sollte es einen Auf- und einen Abstieg geben. Da haben sich dann noch die Verbände dagegen gewehrt. Aber da passiert schon vieles. Und das ist ja aber eins von mehreren Beispielen. Also, CVC ist auch im Beachvolleyball aktuell drin. Da kann man lesen, dass sich Spieler und Spielerinnen sehr darüber beschweren, dass jetzt weniger Teams nur noch antreten, dass die Preisgelder so gesenkt wurden, dass sich die Anreise kaum noch lohnt. Und bei anderen Turnierserien, die jetzt eben nicht vom Weltverband vermarktet werden, freuen sie sich darüber, dass es Obst und Getränke gibt. Sie waren natürlich lange in der Formel 1 mit drin. Und da hat CVC für elf Jahre sein Investment gehalten. Wie man da reingekommen ist und wie man rausgegangen ist, googelt mal Bernie Eggersdorn und CVC. Auch ganz interessant, die Schleife kann jetzt aber nicht drehen an dieser Stelle. Und da gab es aber z.B. dann sehr, sehr deutliche Kritik. Der Force India Teamchef Robert Fernley hat gesagt, all their actions have been taken to extract as much money from the sport as possible and put as little in as possible. Hat er damals dem Guardian gesagt. Er hat sogar davon gesprochen, die Formel 1 sei, ich zitiere ihn jetzt, vergewaltigt worden von CVC. Das ist ja kein so guter Track-Rocker, Jannik. Also woher kommt dann immer dieses Argument zu sagen, Mensch, die haben so viel Vorerfahrung, ist doch alles toll. Wenn ich versuche zu gucken, was haben sie in anderen Sportarten gemacht, dann ist es immer eine Kostenstrafung und es geht immer vor allem darum, mit allen Wegen dieses Investment auszuquetschen, ist ja klar. Dafür ist man ja eine Private Equity Firma.
Ich will da gar nicht großreden, gegenreden eigentlich. Ich will mich auch nicht als Verteidiger von Private Equity dort in diesem Punkt sehen, auf gar keinen Fall. Was dann aber auf der Gegenseite steht, ist bei der Formel 1, dass der Umsatz von 1 auf 1, 8 Milliarden pro Jahr gesteigert wurde in dieser Zeit in diesen elf Jahren und dass die Ausschüttung an die Teams von 250 Millionen auf 1 Milliarde gesteigert wurde.
Aber andererseits wurden auch traditionelle Rennstrecken, die mussten so viel bezahlen, dass sie kurz vor Konkurs standen und dann also nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch Monster und so weiter. Wir haben jetzt Grand Prix 3 in den USA, jetzt schon. Man hat sich völlig daran gewöhnt, dass es Grand Prixs in Wüstenstaaten gibt. Also ja, Wertsteigerung, aber halt da wurden rote Linien definitiv überfahren in diesem Fall.
Absolut. Deutschland hat ja auch drunter gelitten. Also das muss man ja sehen und seitdem Liberty Media bei der Formel 1 drin ist, also die haben das abgekauft damals von CVC, läuft es ja noch deutlich besser. Also man kann ja auch sagen, hey, also seit Liberty Media drin ist, wieso lief es vorher nicht so viel besser noch unter CVC. Also wer weiß, wie es dann ausgesehen hätte, wenn schon, weiß nicht, 2015, es wird ja jetzt immer wieder auf Drive to Survive so als Beispiel abgehoben. Es ist ja unter Liberty Media entstanden und wer weiß, wie es damals dann schon abgegangen wäre. Also man kann es nicht so richtig nachweisen. Also einerseits sind die Erträge hochgegangen, der Umsatz ist hochgegangen. Ja, das spricht auf dieser Seite dann irgendwie für CVC. Andererseits kann man auch gegenhalten, dass Liberty Media seit dem Einstieg da noch mehr erreicht hat. Ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu noch sagen soll. Also die CVC ist sicherlich kein angenehmer und einfacher Partner, aber es stehen am Ende oft hier eben auch Erträge. Also aus wirtschaftlicher Perspektive gesprochen ist es meistens sinnvoll. Aber was am Ende dabei liegen bleibt, das zeigt die Formel 1, das zeigt Rugby, das zeigt – in Frankreich, in Spanien gibt es ja auch Probleme mit CVC. Zumindest wird sich immer darüber beschwert, wie dort zum Beispiel in Spanien das CVC zu viel Daten verlangen würde. Das sind so erste Kritikpunkte, die dort kommen. Andererseits wurde auch dort der Umsatz gesteigert. Also wie gesagt, es gibt mal Vor-
Sie kriegen Ergebnisse hin, aber halt mit Kosten, die sehr rigoros sind. Kann man glaube ich schon so sagen, oder?
Das kann man definitiv so sagen. Es ist wie gesagt, es ist ja auch Knall alter Wirtschaft, die dort auf Sport trifft, was ein emotionales Thema ist. Und ich glaube, da kommt es automatisch dann irgendwie zu Zielkonflikten.
Die berühmten Zielkonflikte. Christoph, was sind da deine Gedanken zu? Weil das ist dieses unauflösbare Spannungsfeld, das uns gesagt wird, es wird sich nichts verändern. Und dass sich aber eigentlich alles verändern muss, damit man eine Wertsteigung hinbekommt. Und dass wir auch an dem, was CVC sonst so gemacht hat, eigentlich ganz gut ablesen können. Ja, da verhalten die sich erwartbar. Es wird dann alles verändert, was geht.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir sind fordernde Partner. Ja, das ist klar. Aber ehrlich gesagt, die, die dafür sind in der Liga, die wollen ja auch so einen Partner. Die wollen ja so jemanden haben, der ihnen hilft, ein paar Dinge zu verändern. Und vielleicht die Dinge, die man sonst nicht aufbrechen kann, aufzubrechen. Das Thema Governance, das ich eben schon angesprochen hatte mit der DFL, wenn es zu dem Deal kommt, wird das extrem lebhaft werden von Diskussionen. Das ist klar. Und wir haben, glaube ich, bei uns in der Bundesliga einen besonders großen Spagat dazu leisten, weil eben, wie ich eben schon mal gesagt habe, diese Clubkultur, die EVs, die Fankultur sehr viel tiefer verankert ist als in vielen anderen. In Englern gibt es ja auch Clubs, die so sind, aber das ist schon ein sehr wichtiger Faktor. Das wissen die natürlich auch und die wissen auch, dass das einen Teil der Werthaltigkeit ausmacht. Und die Frage ist ein bisschen auch, wie gehen die dann damit um? Die sind schon flexibel genug, denke ich, um Dinge genau zu studieren, zu wissen oder zu ahnen, was kann man da machen, was kann man von so was nicht. Die werden auch sehen, mal gucken, wie es läuft. Aber ich glaube, dass die schon wissen, dass sie eine gewisse Vorsicht walten lassen müssen. Das heißt, die verhalten sich schon bei jedem Investment noch anders. Die haben zwar ihre Methoden, ganz klar ihre bestimmten Raster, die die über Dinge drüberlegen, Vergleiche, die sie ziehen. Die werden sagen, wenn das zusammen in der Mediaco läuft, wir geben jetzt mal ein paar Vergleichswerte, was kriegen denn andere liegen, was kriegen die dann, wie sieht es bei euch aus? So müssen wir was machen. So werden die die, ich sag mal, attackieren, im Sinne von, so werden die die antreiben wollen. Gleichzeitig hast du auf der DFL die Leute, die sitzen und sagen, wow, so viel ist drin, ist ja irre, ist ja toll. Wenn man das jetzt mal ausrechnet für unsere Clubs, was dann da hängen bleiben würde, sag mal, auch nicht vergessen. Die Clubs wollen das ja auch ein Stück weit. Teilweise wollen die das. Und dann kommst du auf die Frage an, wie kriege ich das zusammen? Und das wird ein andauernder Kampf werden. Das ist klar. Und ich denke, das wissen die in der DFL auch. Und die CVCs wissen das auch, dass sich das dann ständig dann sich reibt. Und welche Grenzen dann überschritten werden, welche nicht überschritten werden, wer wen wie respektiert, welche Leute am Ende den meisten Einfluss haben. Ich finde, das ist extrem schwer vorherzusagen. Und hängt vom Gesamtumfeld ab, hängt davon ab, wie die nächste Ausschreibung läuft. Das wird extrem spannend. Ich befürchte halt, dass es gar nicht so viel passieren wird, weil man sich lahmlegt gegenseitig. Weil ich eben, wie gesagt, schon nicht glaube oder glaube, ich glaube, die DFL wird sich sehr schwer tun, ihre Interessen zu vertreten, wenn die aber keine Gemeinschaft mit ihren Positionen zu bestimmten Kernfragen gegen oder im Schreiber den Investoren aufbauen können, sind die ja nicht handlungsfähig. Und dann wird der Investor auch merken, okay, da kann ich jetzt gar nichts machen, weil es steht alles. Das heißt aber auch, keiner profitiert. Die Gefahr ist auch da. Da hast du einen Deal und der wird im Endeffekt überhaupt nicht richtig, kann gar nicht umgesetzt werden. Oder du kannst nicht die Möglichkeiten erforschen, die du vielleicht hast, weil du einfach gar nicht handlungsfähig bist. Ich glaube, die Gefahr ist relativ groß, wenn es dann dazu kommt.
Ich weiß ja auch so, dass schon sehr viele Dinge vordefiniert sind. Also ich will das jetzt nicht kritisieren, aber es ist ja Fakt, dass die DFL sicher auch aus Gründen, um den Fans entgegenzukommen, nicht nur die roten Linien schriftlich fixiert hat, sondern auch zum Beispiel schon die Geldverteilung ganz genau in Töpfe und so weiter aufgeteilt hat. Und man kann sich ja sehr gut vorstellen, dass eins der ersten Dinge wäre, dass die CVC reinkommt und sagt, ihr wollt 200 Millionen in Antipiraterie stecken, spart's euch, nicht mal die NFL kriegt das hin und die investieren viel, viel mehr. Wir machen das Geld anders und dann ist das zwar vielleicht möglich, aber es ist ja eigentlich schon relativ viel gerade vordefiniert. Es ist fast so, als würden die Vereine sagen, wir wissen ja eigentlich schon, wie wir es am besten machen. Wir haben es ja nur nicht gemacht, weil wir hatten keine Lust in der letzten Zeit. Und jetzt brauchen wir halt die Kohle und deswegen machen wir es jetzt.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, würde ich jetzt, und dass ich es jetzt belegen kann oder auch möchte, es für extrem naiv halten, wenn die DFL so eine Aufteilung da veröffentlicht und wie sie das gerne machen würden, wenn das nicht zumindest in den Grundsätzen mit den Partnern schon mal vorbesprochen worden wäre. Weil das weißt du ja, dass du dann sofort vor die Wand läufst. Und das glaube ich eigentlich nicht. Also ich glaube schon, dass das Teil der Ausschreibungsunterlagen ist und war und dass die Partner wissen, dass der Partner, der mögliche noch übrig ist, weiß, dass das der Plan ist und auch schon in irgendeiner Form gesagt haben wird, kommt ungefähr hin. Und dass die das nicht einfach so mit dem Arsch umschmeißen in der ersten Woche, wenn die Mediacode eingetragen wird. Weil da wissen die ganz genau, dass sie sich damit sofort unmöglich machen. Die Belius ist ja nicht ungeschickt. Aber der weiß natürlich auch, wie er sie erreicht.
Da muss man vielleicht noch kurz einen Hintergrund zu sagen. Ihr wisst das natürlich. Aber er war bei Goldman Sachs vorher und war da zuständig für Daimler Chrysler, den Merger. Er hat dann später die feindliche Übernahme Mannesmann-Voldervorn in Deutschland gemacht. Er war Beraterin von der Regierung Merkel. Also lest euch da mal durch, recherchiert ein bisschen zu ihm. Das ist jemand, der hat jetzt schon ein paar Dinge erlebt. Und wenn ihr eben sagt, harter Verhandlungspartner weiß, was er tut. Ja, also der hat schon ganz, ganz, ganz große Dinge durchgezogen.
Also das wird spannend. Aber wie gesagt, solche Dinge werden in der Regel schon vorher mal abgeklopft. Informell. Wenn das die DFL nicht gemacht hätte, dann könnten die gleich einpacken. Also das glaube ich.
Sie haben es gemacht. Du weißt, das darfst du bloß nicht so sagen. Alles gut. Das ergibt ja auch sehr viel Sinn so. Aber was, wenn wir dann versuchen, zu einem Fazit dieses Gesprächs zu kommen? Ich habe das Gefühl, Jannik, es muss sich was an der Bundesliga verändern. Denn man verdient zu wenig Geld im Vergleich zu anderen Märkten, vor allem eben bei der Auslandsvermarktung. Und die Lösung, die man für sich gefunden hat, ist die einfachste. Nämlich wir gehen nicht an Geldverteilung ran. Wir gehen nicht daran, dass der Wettbewerb ein Wettbewerb ist. Weil dann müssten wir die Großen ärgern, die gerade sehr viel Geld damit verdienen. Sondern man geht den anderen Weg, der auch nicht illegitim ist. Wir verbessern die Art und Weise des Produkts, wie wir es verkaufen. Also wir bauen eben, die Infrastruktur wird verändert. Wir bereiten uns letztlich dafür vor, dass wir zu einem B2C-Unternehmen werden könnten. Also sprich, irgendwann könnten auch Leute bei der DFL ein Abo abschließen und direkt dort die Spiele sehen. Also lässt sich B2B zu B2C-Transformation so ein bisschen. Das scheint der Weg zu sein. Wie erfolgsversprechend, glaubst du, ist der? Wenn CVC jetzt einsteigt, dann könnten ja auch die Fans alles kaputt machen. Wenn die sich absprechen und jetzt für Spielabbrüche zum Beispiel sorgen, das ist, glaube ich, eine nicht so irrelle Gefahr.
Ja, also wie erfolgsversprechender ist, das gibt natürlich sehr viel Spekulation dabei. Also ich bin da irgendwie einfach von berufsfähig auch ein bisschen pessimistisch, glaube ich. Ob das wirklich so diese Wachstumssteigerungen erreicht werden können, das bezweifle ich jetzt einfach mal. Ich würde das halt eher aus einer… Also man hätte das Ganze auch zum Beispiel mit Fremdkapital finanzieren können, dann wäre diese ganze Investoren-Diskussion auch gar nicht aufgekommen. Aber das könnte man diesen Topf ja auch mal aufmachen und sagen, was man davon wegstreichen könnte, wenn man das ganze Fremdkapital finanziert hätte. Dann wären keine 300 Millionen für… die man jetzt vorstrecken muss. Dann wären da keine Ahnung… Weiß nicht, ob man eine Plattform für 164 Millionen bauen muss. Internationalisierung 183 Millionen. Was will Heidenheim in den USA? Das verstehe ich nicht. Kann man auch zusammenstreichen. Was 126 Millionen nationale Töpfe, Piraterie passt, ist natürlich ein Ärgernis. Aber du kriegst es mit rund 46 Millionen wahrscheinlich gar nicht hin. Wie auch immer man es dreht, kann man diesen ganzen Topf auf jeden Fall sehr stark auch eindampfen und man könnte das Ganze dann theoretisch auf Rebkapital finanziert machen. Dafür müssten aber natürlich die Vereine gegenseitig einstehen füreinander. Und das wird nicht passieren, weil Bayern nicht die Schulden von Schalke übernehmen möchte sozusagen. Bayern möchte die für Schalke einstehen. Was ich auch verstehe, aber das würde auf jeden Fall sehr viel Wind aus dieser Nummer nehmen. Und ich glaube halt, dass die Bundesliga – der Unix-Helling-Point der Bundesliga ist ja letztlich nicht, dass man mit der Premier League konkurrieren will, sondern nicht damit konkurrieren kann, oder mit der La Liga, weil die einfach auch ganz andere demografische Vorteile haben, Sprachekultur und so weiter. Und ich glaube, dass man diese Ligen gar nicht aufholen kann, zumindest die Premier League nicht. Die La Liga mag vielleicht in Reichweite sein, was den kommerziellen Umsatz angeht, aber die Premier League ist völlig enteilt. Ich glaube, die meisten Fans geben sich auch völlig damit zufrieden, dass man sagt, wir wollen hin und wieder mal die Premier League ärgern und wollen da mal ganz gerne vielleicht auch mal ein Europa League Finale spielen. Aber so wie es jetzt ist, ist es doch eigentlich ganz schön. Und ich glaube, das könnte man auch einfach durch Kostenregulierung auf eigener Seite mal hinbekommen und damit mal anfangen. Und diese Internationalisierung zum Beispiel, diese 103, 8 Millionen, die ich angesprochen habe, könnte man auch aus eigener Kasse bezahlen. Das könnte FC Bayern, die es ja jetzt bislang auch schon so gemacht haben, einfach so weitertreiben. Also ein bisschen Heidenheim oder Augsburg – oder ich tue mir leid, dass ich diese Vereine jetzt nenne und die dann in den gleichen Topf schmeiße. Da kann ich jetzt noch ein paar weitere nennen, bis die für den amerikanischen Markt interessant werden. Da muss noch einiges passieren. Ich glaube, das wird keiner von uns diese Dreierrunde noch erleben. Ich verstehe diesen Topf einfach nicht, und da fängt es schon für mich an. Deswegen glaube ich, dass dieser ganze Investoren-Deal ziemlich stark zugunsten der Großen wie Bayern und Dortmund geht und die Ungleichheit dieser Liga noch vergrößern wird. Das ist für die Bundesliga sicherlich nicht gut.
Ich denke, dass aus meiner Wahrnehmung schon der Bundesliga wirklich guttun würde, mehr Wirtschafts-Know-How zu bekommen. Dergestalt, dass es aus anderen Branchen einfließt. Weil der Fußball aus meiner Wahrnehmung schon sehr wagenburgartig da steht und sich im Prinzip ja um die anderen gar nicht kümmern muss, weil da geht es rauf und rauf. Und ich glaube, dass der Branche insgesamt bei uns guttun würde. Und deswegen glaube ich, dieses Projekt strategischer Investor ist eine Möglichkeit, um mehr alternative Sichtweisen reinzukriegen und den Fußball voranzubringen. Mir ist klar, dass da viele Grenzen sind, dass das sehr strittig ist, dass das auch ein schwieriger Partner ist. Vielleicht brauchen die in der DFL gerade einen schwierigen Partner. Das kann sein. Der einer, der sehr fordernd auftritt, um einfach ein Stück voranzukommen. Deswegen finde ich das eigentlich richtig. Das gilt auf der Klubebene im hohen Maße, wo du immer mehr Leute hast, die aus der sonstigen Wirtschaft da reingehen. Weil es gibt eigentlich zu viele Fußballer immer noch, die da die Clubs managen und zu wenig Leute, die einfach gute Manager sind. Ich habe mir jetzt lagen lassen vor einiger Zeit von jemandem, der lange im Fußball, der Fußball gut kennt, der sagt, ich kriege ja nicht Anrufe von Leuten aus großen deutschen Konzernen, die fragen, wie kann ich Manager werden im Fußball? Das sind einfach Fans, die wollen da rein und ich finde das cool als Branche und die wissen natürlich auch, da kann man sehr gut verdienen und die sehen dann, ich komme nicht mehr in Vorstand, wie komme ich da rein? Der Fußball ist auch ein Irrenhaus auf eine gewisse Art und Weise und das macht das Managen da echt nicht einfach, aber das tut dem Fußball gut. Ich finde auch, dass man diesen speziellen, dieses Vereinsdenken ein Stück weit braucht, um die Leute an Bord zu halten, um die Fankultur zu behalten. Ich bin selber Jugendtrainer in einem kleinen Verein. Das ist wirklich Verein, Verein, Verein, ohne Geld und nur mit Spaß und Begeisterung und so weiter. Und das ist total klasse, dass es das so gibt. Flächendeckend im Land und das darf man auch nicht riskieren. Ich glaube, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt, da Kompromisse zu finden. Es wird schwierig sein, die auszuarbeiten und alle mitzunehmen. Das ist ganz klar. Und wenn wir das nicht schaffen, dann würde ich sagen, es läuft die Bundesliga-Gefahr, dass wir in zehn Jahren nur noch begrenzt wettbewerbsfähig sind. Und – wir haben gar nicht darüber gesprochen, aber das ist sicherlich schon in anderen Sendungen gemacht – und dass dann Vereinzelclubs sagen, das brauchen wir hier nicht mehr. Die ist ja nicht tot. Und dann gehen die halt raus. Das kann auch passieren. Und dann fliegt die DFL sowieso auseinander. Dann spätestens sowieso. Also wenn es nicht schon vorher passiert.
Also wenn ich so versuchen müsste, so meine Gedanken jetzt auch angestoßen von euch zusammenzufassen. Ich weiß, das wusste ich schon vorher. Wenn man mit Menschen mit wirtschaftlichem Hintergrund spricht, dann blicken die erstmal anders auf dieses. Weil da nämlich auch diese Modelle viel, viel normaler und gelernter sind als eben in der Bundesliga. Ich komme aber an einem Grundgedanken nicht vorbei. Und ich habe das Gefühl, aktuell funktioniert die Bundesliga nicht. Und zwar weder als Wettbewerb noch wirtschaftlich. Ein Teil der Zustimmung für diesen Investorendeal liegt auch daran, weil Vereine jetzt schon zukünftige Einnahmen verkauft haben und dass ihr Mitglieder nicht zugeben wollen. Wir haben ja eine Mehrheit von Vereinen, die das möchte, egal ob das jetzt eine Zweidrittelmehrheit ist oder vielleicht noch eine einfache Mehrheit. Die ist da. Und dafür gibt es Gründe. Und einer der Gründe dafür ist, Vereine sind nicht gut im Wirtschaften. Es ist ein defizitäres Geschäft. Übrigens auch für alle, die bisher Geld oder für viele, die Geld reinstecken, also die Lizenznehmer. Sky gäbe es halt ohne die Bundesliga in Deutschland nicht mehr. Deswegen müssen sie dafür zahlen. Aber Geld verdienen sie damit auch nicht. Und das ist das eine Problem. Wir finanzieren quasi, also wir stecken Geld in ein System, das nicht funktioniert und das dann auch quasi weiter kaschieren kann, dass es nicht funktioniert. Und das zweite Problem, glaube ich, und da will man eben offenbar einfach nicht ran, weil man da so viel im Kopf verändern muss. Die Bundesliga als Wettbewerb ist kein Wettbewerb. Und es spielt eben eine Rolle, ob der FC Bayern Elfmannmeister wird. Und es spielt auch eine Rolle, ob die Alternative zum FC Bayern dann ein Leverkusen ist, das von einem Milliardenkonzern finanziert wird. Und es spielt eine sehr wichtige Rolle, dass du als Köln-Fan und du als HSV-Fan, ihr beide werdet – es tut mir leid – ihr werdet nie wieder deutscher Meister werden, wenn die Bundesliga so bleibt, wie sie jetzt ist. Und das ist ja eigentlich total absurd. Es war noch nie so, dass alle 18 Meister werden konnten, aber es waren zumindest mehr. Und man wusste vor allem eigentlich, wenn sich etwas über längere Zeit verbessert, dann kann man in den Bereich der Teams kommen, die Meister werden können. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz grundlegendes Problem. Und das ist an ganz vielen dann Symptomen zu erkennen, unter anderem eben, dass die Stadien nicht voll sind, dass die Bevorteilung des Fernsehzuschauers vor dem Stadion Zuschauer aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen war, aber dass sie dazu geführt hat, dass das Produkt auch im Fernsehen nicht mehr gut aussieht. Und das sind für mich eigentlich die beiden eigentlichen Themen, die man angehen müsste. Und es kann sogar sein, dass wenn ein Investor reinkommt und der dann der Buhmann ist, man vielleicht manches davon dann umgesetzt und angegangen bekommt. Ich bezweifle es aber irgendwie, weil ich habe das Gefühl, man hat immer noch den Eindruck, wir brauchen nur eine Plattform und dann kaufen schon die ganzen US-Amerikaner und die Chinesen und die Japanerinnen. Die kaufen dann alle ihre Abos. Glaub ich nicht. Glaub ich ja, wenn ich gucke sehr viel Fußball, ich gucke sehr viel Bundesliga, ich kann sagen, das ist nicht immer gut. Hat viele Gründe. Und ich habe das Gefühl, man umschifft einfach nur diese sehr unangenehmen Fragen, verschiebt die auf die Zukunft. Und das ist sehr unbefriedigend, weil das auch für die Fans und die sind halt hier in Deutschland der Kern des Fußballs. Da kann Alex Zorniger erzählen, was man will. Wir haben es während der Pandemie gesehen. Als keiner hingekommen ist in die Stadien, war es ein anderes Spiel und es war fürchterlich. Es gab doch niemanden, der gesagt hat, boah, ich wünsche mir die Geisterspiele zurück. Das war aber geil, wo man gehört hat, was sie sagen. Das ist so mein Gedanke. Und dann haben wir noch 50 plus 1 und 50 plus 1 wird, also in der Art und Weise, wir haben das gerade schon wieder dehnt bis zum Brechen. Das könnte ja sogar dazu führen, dass das Bundeskartellamt nochmal, also wird es jetzt nochmal aufmachen und wahrscheinlich sagt das Bundeskartellamt irgendwann, ey, wenn ihr so viele Ausnahmen immer macht für 50 plus 1, dann muss die Regel jetzt wirklich weg. Es ist eine irre Sackgasse, auf die man da zusteuert. Aber ich danke euch, dass ihr mir diese Sackgasse ein bisschen ausgeleuchtet habt. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, wir haben doch so viele Themen, wir haben gar nicht über Tipico zum Beispiel gesprochen und so weiter und so fort. Wir haben nicht drüber gesprochen, wie die Liga, wie viele da einzelne Menschen verdient haben durch den Einstieg von CVC. Da gibt es jetzt sogar schon Prozesse und so weiter. Vielleicht können wir das mal irgendwann nachholen. Aber vielen, vielen Dank euch, dass ihr mit dabei habt. Herzlichen Dank an Christoph Neßhöver vom Manager-Magazin. Danke dir, lieber Christoph. Und toi, toi, toi für den FC.
Wir können jede Hilfe gebrauchen. Wenn irgendein Stürmer weiß, der auch früher wieder mal ein Tor schießt, würden wir den sofort nehmen, egal wie alt, wie groß, wie klein.
Ich hätte dir Jannik empfohlen, aber der spielt ja defensives Mittelfeld, hat er uns vorhin verraten.
Ja, ich kann es auch nicht machen.
Ich wüsste beim HSV aber auch, ich glaube, da kann euch keiner weiterhelfen, sagen wir mal so.
Und vor allem, ihr dürftet ja, nicht mal Jannik, dürftet ihr ja registrieren. Also da sind ja die Probleme nochmal ganz anderer Art. Aber dementsprechend danke dir, dass du trotz der angespannten fußballerischen Lage trotzdem Lust hattest, über Fußball indirekt zu sprechen. Und dante danke an Jannik Tillar von Kapital. Danke dir lieber Jannik, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank auch.
Und dann danke ich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern. Der Rasenfunk ist, anders als die Bundesliga, rein crowdfinanziert. Wir sind paywall, werbungsponsorenfrei, aus sehr, sehr guten Gründen. Und wir werden nur von euch da draußen finanziert. Und in dieser Folge danke ich Tobi W. Steffen, Stefan Hoki-Hoffmann, Clemens Pötzsch, Chris aus MD, Nico Jünke, Jonas und Eiko. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club gegangen, haben uns unterstützt und sich dort auch registriert. Ganz herzlichen Dank dafür. Bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gewogen. Bis bald! Von Ihnen unterstützt. Danke. Uns nur der Rasen.